good morning John it's a day of the week
day of the month a month and a year I'm
not even trying anymore
what it is John is the day after Super
Bowl Sunday and I'm sorry to all you
Steelers fans but in your face this is
the first time maybe ever that I cared
about a Super Bowl two reasons why like
Green Bay Packers one there's a lot of
Wisconsinites here in Missoula and so I
don't like to see my friends cry and the
Green Bay fans take it serious because
the second reason why I love the Green
Bay Packers they're owned by people tens
of thousands of people people don't get
anything return for buying Green Bay
Packer stock because the group of
hackers are a nonprofit organization
it's a football team National Football
League football team just won the Super
Bowl big deal team community or
nonprofit
why aren't they all like that it's clear
that it works they won the Super Bowl
and they have the most dedicated fans of
any football team in the world oh hell
you say that the winners of the Super
Bowl are the world champions because the
rest the world is fighting so hard but
anyhow all the rest of football teams
owned by a some rich person or a small
group of rich people they didn't just
win the Super Bowl they don't have the
most dedicated fans of any football team
and they're not an opera Vittorio sation
that donates the profits of the team
back into the community actually I just
spent a little bit of time researching
this on the internet turns out that the
NFL has specifically forbidden another
team like the Green Bay Packers from
entering the NFL they will not allow
that it's too successful all of those
rich people gonna make money of their
football teams if it's owned by the
community I'll still pay to use a
horrible brand crack idea for you had an
idea take a picture of this or video of
this and then annotate or link every
book and also every little knick-knack e
item to a review or the story of that
book or item it would only take like 200
hours work and then that would be
totally awesome right yeah that's just
gonna sit in there and chew away my
brain that one that's not getting out
I'll start with the Super Bowl ah it's
not about football really is it it's
about eating food hanging out with
friends and watching commercials and I
have to say I'm getting really tired of
coca-cola commercial skok ago I don't
know if you know this is water with
bubbles and sugar in it turns out water
with bubbles and sugar in it cannot
solve the world's problems
it cannot defuse a dragon that is
attacking adorable monkey people you
know what you and everyone else in the
world
have in common a lot more than just
coca-cola stop trying to convince me
that bubbly sugar water is going to
solve all the world's problems because
it's frickin bubbly sugar water you know
we like Coca Cola because it's candy in
a bottle and rent counterbalance amazing
story there is a black Labrador a dog in
Japan that can smell colon cancer on
your breath they can also smell it in
your poop but also on your breath this
dog is just as accurate as a colonoscopy
which is the thing where they stick a
camera up your butt and look around at
discovering whether or not people have
colon cancer one day I went to live in a
while but you can walk into a doctor's
office and there's a black Labrador
sitting there and he walks up to you and
sniffs you and he either barks or he
doesn't bark and though that would be
kind of a horrible way to buy you have
cancer and he doesn't even have to spell
your body smells your breath that is
just weird
though it is a dog so it's probably
gonna sniff your butt anyway the
Catherine my wife guest-starred with me
and an episode of Hank plays Lego Harry
Potter it's hilarious because she's
hilarious and you should watch it
because it's adorable and me John
wheezywaiter Alex day and elmify are all
getting together to create a linked up
vu calm space Viacom is like question
Tuesdays except forever and always so
basically there's links down there you
go and you ask questions and we will
answer them in video form and then you
can click on other people's questions
and see our video replies it's lots of
fun and if you actually sign it for the
site instead of giving anonymous
questions I will be much more elected to
answer your questions but John and Alex
and Craig and Emma and I will all be
answering questions on Viacom you should
check it out and there's more amazing
stuff there's always more amazing stuff
but I'm just going to link to that in
the end screen John I will see you on
Wednesday
you